hello I'm Andy hunt from Wolfram
research and I'm here to talk about a
new feature in Mathematica 11.3 called
presenter tools that Mathematica has had
the ability to present notebooks and
slideshows for many releases but now
it's version 11.3 we've added an
integrator toolkit that provides
additional functionality to help you
author and present your notebooks to the
world to create a new presentation
choose file new presenter notebook from
the menus this brings up a dialog from
which you can choose from several custom
themes along with the optional ability
to change the font sets you can pre-fill
your presentation with sample content or
start off with an empty notebook
presenter tools as an integrated tool
bar which provides quick access to
commonly used features inserting new
slides inserting new styled cell
templates and various formatting buttons
to help you modify cell content
there are also buttons to increase and
decrease cell margins to position your
content around the screen once you've
modified the cell formatting you can
apply those changes back to the style
sheet choosing which options to apply
from the dialog this will also update
similar Styles in your notebook and all
future instances of the same style
there's also a companion formatting
palette available from the toolbar menu
also in the menu is a dialog where you
can change keyboard shortcuts used when
navigating your presentation to divide
existing content into individual slides
you can add a new slide break as I did
before or you can set your default slide
breaks based on cell styles a slight
break cell will be added above each cell
style YouTube
the cell styles you choose will also be
added to the toolbars cell style menu if
you've added content by hand instead of
going through the menus again you can
also click refresh the slide breaks in
your notebook
presentation notebooks are responsive so
increasing and decreasing the notebook
window size will scale the content
accordingly by default graphics will
scale on your presentation
but you can choose whether or not the
graphics are responsive through the
toolbar menu the window size menu in the
toolbar contains several common the used
settings if you're creating content to
fit a specific monitor or projectors
resolution to see an overview of your
presentation clicking on the outline
palette will provide a thumbnail view of
your presentation along with clickable
icons when you're ready to present your
notebook
click start presentation presenter tools
provides a menu in the upper right
corner which contains navigation
controls as well as toggling a
navigation bar access to the style
palette and access to the presentation
controls dialog choosing in presentation
takes you back to working view the view
with the toolbar one helpful feature of
presenter tools are side note these are
special cells are visible in the
authoring view but are hidden from view
during your presentation they can be
accessed from the bottom of the cell
style menu
a pallet collating these notes can be
accessed from the toolbar and during
your presentation side notes can also be
accessed from the menu for side notes
code you also have the ability to paste
code from the pallet into your notebook
and if you right click it will paste and
evaluate these are just some of the many
features of presenter tools I appreciate
your time and look forward to your
comments and experiences using preserve
tools thank you